all right Samantha yes Samantha where'd
you grow up where are you from
originally uh I was I was born in New
Mexico but I was raised uh right here in
Los Angeles
tell me about your family
um the woman who took me in she was a
high school teacher at
um Hollywood High she didn't really have
much
um she took you in meaning you uh she
ended she ended up adopting me somehow
um
yeah okay my biological grandmother
um
basically took me out of a drug house I
was in a drawer I wasn't being taken
care of at all she my biological
grandmother worked at um CYFD in that
town so she was able to quietly and very
quickly
um get me out of that house
um and get me out of that town
um I was taken to
a woman and she
took me from
El Paso Airport in Texas and took me to
Los Angeles and
basically raised me here and how was
your childhood with her
um
it was Rocky solely because she was a
great she she was actually very
Progressive and very strong for her she
was strong-willed
um she's great woman she was raised in a
Tiny Town in Santo very racial she got
out of it came to Los Angeles
um met a black man in the 90s that
wasn't perfect she had to cut her
like she had to cut her ties with her
family because she wanted to be with a
black man and
um they didn't get married for a really
long time for it I was never adopted by
him because of it
um growing up in the 90s
with that racial tension here
um made it extremely hard and kids are
mean they and they're just asking honest
questions but for somebody like me why
is this black man picking you up you
know you're a little white girl
um I'm obviously not black so it just
always raised questions people would
stop us on the street all the time to
make sure I was safe
um
it was it was ugly going into
restaurants oh you look just like
um your mother she didn't look anything
like me it was just because we were both
White
uh so people were just ugly
um and it didn't help that it was a
constant reminder for me that I didn't
belong
there
so I left home really
early really early uh
let me back up a little bit when when
she got me she took me to the hospital
because my head was flat my neck was
kinked
um it seemed like I was pretty abused
so
it is my idea that my grandmother was
trying to hide something
and just kind of get me out of there
Hush Hush my my neck still is kinked to
this day so there was some damage that
was done uh the woman who got me
massaged my head until it was round
again so there was a lot of trauma that
happened already from from Jump Street
then there was this racial
war that was going on kind of inside of
you know
society and then it affects our little
family that we had we didn't I didn't
have any sister Aunts Uncles anybody to
grow up with because of the this the
segregation almost in
yeah the parents were good
you know they they did the best I went
to magnet schools out here uh I went to
really good schools you ran away from
your family early
yes why'd you do that
I still I didn't feel connected there
they kind of had their own I had a lot
of problems and they didn't know
how to help me too
um
and I think
I maybe did a part of that I felt really
alone
with them where'd you go
I started Living on the streets when I
was 13 here in Los Angeles
um they tried to help me they put me
into a receipt of Psych Ward right here
Reseda and I awolt
you're into drugs uh yes I started using
drugs in high school
um and anything I mean because Morning
Glory flowers that are just grow out
just take those boil them drink it
yeah and we would just trip balls for a
couple of days 13 14. yeah
on the streets in Los Angeles so
um in order to are you supporting
yourself
we're stealing food
mostly and we would all share there's a
group of see I was the only kid though I
was the only kid they were all older I I
lied to them I was 15 doing this and so
the state is going to let I'm going to
keep getting arrested right and picked
up when you're that young they were 18
you know somewhere even 21 23 you know
we're all just living on the streets
together
um we lived in the wash in a tent
uh
I remember we would take a um
a cart and we would just cook food on we
would took the cart over and we would
cook food on the cart like that really
young I was really young stealing
alcohol
um
most of those people are actually dead
now
so
would your life go from there
do you finish High School Yes actually I
do with that lifestyle
I was picked up and institutionalized
for two and a half years and I
was able to lose myself in school
so
I did miss a lot of my high school I was
in and out of the Reseda institution I
took a Greyhound bus and squatted in New
Mexico with a kid for about six seven
months got arrested out there got prop
packed to California because
you know but it was
I lived a really wild I was pretty wild
when I was young
so I shaved my head in order to live in
that I stopped showering
so I was a child hobo just
as nasty as you can get and that was the
safest I could be too
so
the grocer I was the better
um
finally I was arrested
uh and taken to a place
called Provo Canyon School
and um the average stay there is I
believe six to nine months
um
I was hoping that I was going to get out
eventually they never wanted to tell me
that they were going to keep me there
until I was 18.
um
right when I got in they shaved my head
um I I heard about other girls getting
their heads like completely shaved I had
a mohawk so when I wore it down though I
still had hair so I still looked like a
girl with a mohawk or not
um
all of my hair was gone I had nothing I
just
they put you in
sweats all the same color sweats just a
sweat top sweat bottoms uh they
completely stripped me naked
um
the people that worked here the
strangest part about this school of this
institution is what it was It was a
Mental Health institution and
um
for kids
and uh the strange thing is is that
the people that worked there the staff
were all fresh out of high school
they were going to BYU they had little
life experience on
don't know why these
kids were in charge they were
I don't know anything and I'm 33. you
know so I just don't understand how
21 year olds 20 year olds could help
children that have been severely
traumatized by lots of their their girls
there with
trichotillomania pull out all of their
hair
um these are girls that were
traumatized and needed help
therapists came in and we had groups and
we had
um
stuff like that but there weren't
therapists there 24 7.
there's staff there's children you know
probably maybe going for some sort of
therapeutic thing who knows what they
were going to school for it was probably
just an easy job you know an inside job
I get to babysit babysit kids but that's
how they looked at it they they babysat
us
um that's not what
all of these kids or what the parents
think is going on either they think they
are sending their kid to get
help okay
and it doesn't it's it's
so you got out of there at 18. yeah yeah
and they uh I just wanted to say this
too they too fed me
um when I was well of weight like
probably 140.
um to give that a I'm about 130 right
now just to get that
um they would tube feed me and they
would leave a tube on the side of my
face and tape it and then just pour a
boost down it three times a day yeah and
the tube would just
be stuck in your throat so all day you
have to gag like something's in so
with a shaped head and a tube
uh
this place is really strange
um it's it you see it on Sci-Fi movies
you know how they shape little kids and
they put them in you know and they do
strange things to them but um you know
that that really happens
a lot
so when you were when you finally got
out of there you would you do with your
life
um
you're basically an adult
I am an adult and uh one of the main
reasons why they
took me to this place was because I
didn't have a place to I was so wild
that I just lived on the streets
they had to keep me there so because of
that right and because I was a little
you know I mean he lives on the streets
I must be a little crazy right
um
I was still on the streets when
they they didn't help me like get a
place or uh
they just kept me until my 18th birthday
luckily I graduated top of my class
um even took a lot of courses at BYU and
I was able to
just do school work constantly there
really really that's all I did there
so I excelled in that
more of a
I got out I was still homeless though
got a band
that's right living in California
I started doing drugs it's not like that
place helped me with anything
um so I was still the same I still had
the same issues
the abandonment issues the um
the the connection I needed as a
familial connection I needed
um
was was I think taken to me really by
Society it was how ugly Society was I
think I could have maybe progressed
really well with them
um even if they were alone with no you
know
siblings or anything
um
I ended up
I got out in 07.
Market crashed here in 08.
it was ridiculous
so I decided to move to New Mexico where
it was cheaper my biological I knew my
biological family lived there
and I kind of wanted to have some sort
of connection it was cheap I was able to
buy a house in Carlsbad New Mexico for
sixty thousand dollars when I was 19.
yeah so
things out there
um
found out my
my biological family is real
real messed up real messed up so
um I ended up on
you know out here I was doing
psychedelics smoking a lot of weed
um out there it was meth it was
um
harder drugs so uh
man
started shooting up meth
and um
my veins were gone
which happens to a lot of women our
veins aren't as ropey as as you know men
veins we don't got we don't have it like
that so
women I think deteriorate a little bit
faster when they start using the needle
than men do
um
I was only using the needle for a few
months and my veins were blown
I had to flip upside down and blow out
my neck vein
like that
in order to hit
I am 20 years old and I'm in a really
there's a
Predators I mean there's Predators
everywhere right but um
they especially love it when
you're alone
and you have to flip upside down and
trust somebody will
hit your vein right
puts you in a really vulnerable position
so um
that was in that vulnerable position as
a lot of women are
and uh
I ended up yeah I killed I killed a man
who
um gave me way too many drugs when I was
flipped upside down
took me out into a garage
outside of town
and um
he gave me his truck to leave
it's really strange he was high too
though
I believe he had some frontal lobe
damage from a motorcycle accident
um so he wasn't all there
doing drugs with me and I wasn't all
there because I was doing you know drugs
with him and uh
yes
man
he died he ended up dying I stabbed him
I stabbed him in the chest one time for
what purpose
well he asked me to if you want me to be
really honest he asked me to
um we were fighting
over his vehicle he took me out to his
garage and promised me that he had uh
water jugs out there because my water
had just gotten shut off he did not have
water jugs out there he worked for the
oil field a man started
uh banging on the garage door saying
that he needed to go to work
thankfully because he had a mallet in
his hand and the last thing he told me
was you are going to
you're going to need
um
you're gonna need this or you're going
to need some
like self-defense
you're gonna need
um
that's what he implied to me
and uh
he kept trying to touch me
I think he thought that since he gave me
dope and he gave me a lot of it that I
would sleep with him
but it had the
adverse effect it was more of a super
paranoid don't touch me
um why did you give me so much drugs why
are we now out in the middle of nowhere
with no water uh paranoia
so
I can't promise that that paranoia was
real
does that make sense and maybe that's
just my own guilt
um but I'm pretty sure taking you know
lying to a girl saying giving her a lot
of drugs you know
taking her out into a garage where
there's no water and
um I ended up having to take his truck
that guy came to come get him for work
who's in the middle of the night too so
I'm assuming he worked graveyard
yeah it's a really strange we're all
high so nothing kind of really makes
sense we're not doing anything logically
why you took me out to that garage if he
knew he had to go to work
is weird
then he had to give me his truck
well why did you do that to me
so in my mind I'm gonna hide this truck
teachable lesson I'll give it back to
him eventually I don't need his truck
you know
well we're all high so that was my plan
you know we're going to get his truck
back but did you get caught
I got caught what
you murdered somebody did you get caught
oh yeah I got charged for it
absolutely
absolutely well I told the police what
happened
I said this guy gave me a lot of drugs
um took me out in the middle of nowhere
and lied to me
so I hit his truck you know just like a
[ __ ] you how dare you do that to me what
was all that about
you know
um
and when the you know fight ensued uh he
died and he's like stab me
you won't do it
you know you stupid [ __ ] you won't do
it
do it
he won't [ __ ] stab me
well I did
yeah I guess it doesn't seem very
logical you know but I was high
um
and I was scared
and I was just given a bunch of drugs
and this guy's angry at me now
I was trying to get his truck back for
him okay he was at my house where's my
truck I was like all right fine I'll
give it to you all right said hey will
you go he didn't want me to leave he's
like I don't want you to leave you're
gonna stay here with me until I get my
truck back
we had somebody else who was very high
go get the truck how much time how much
time did you get I got
um I got I got six years flat two on
Pearl
they charged me with first degree
premeditated murder
um
I fought it in trial
for 18 months
uh they gave me
a [ __ ] attorney that was
dying he died shortly after my trial
um heart complications so they gave me
this attorney that didn't do anything
probably got paid I'm pretty sure he got
paid the same regardless
um
he didn't put on any defense
um
except that the guy that I killed was a
known uh registered uh sex offender he
was known pedophile in that town he is
actually known for drugging girls and
doing that exact thing so
um
that was in my favor and I was scared
when it happened
um I was high when it happened yeah
nobody can
it could have happened to anybody is
what I'm saying any girl hi like on this
Skid Row Street right now
could happen to any of them and then
they'll pay for it
dearly dearly I was in the interrogation
room
um so messed up
I was passing out on the
interrogation I couldn't even open a
bottle of water
because my hands were so swollen
remember I have no circulation
all the all the needle use so my hands
are swollen my feet are swollen
um
the cop asked me if I'm okay I said no
I am not okay
and uh
yeah I was charged with first degree
murder
for that
um
to top it off when they put you in
prison
they um
categorize You by charges
so
if you're in there for murder you know
then you're in there with all the other
murders
and I don't necessarily know if I really
kind of fit the murder type you know I
mean I did live a really wild life
um but
not like that not I didn't think um
I didn't think I was ever gonna kill
anybody does that make sense
um
these girls in here absolutely some of
them
um
are insane
and uh
yeah that's when you realize that this
the prison is just a mental health
crisis
it's just a bunch of people with trauma
you know I I hate the clean I hate the
scent you know hurt people hurt people
uh yes that's exactly what happens you
don't have to hurt people if you're hurt
but
um
that's the only way it happens and yeah
a lot of
when you're thrown into
um
a position where uh
you're gonna need to be in there for a
while
then you kind of switch up who you are
right
if you're gonna be put in a cage you
know like an animal you're probably
going to start acting and behaving
um as such
so
that's what I did
that's what I did in there
I survived great I think
but I was tattooing
I was fighting
for
minimal things
um
I've gouged out eyes
um
I did horrible things in there and
horrible things were done to me as well
got a concussion I had to go up to the
medical ward for a while
um to even
my head my body weren't connected I
guess you would say I was knocked you
know my head was knocked so
in order for me to like walk proper I
wasn't I can't go back out into
population if you can't walk right so
um
turned into a complete animal
and then it makes you kind of question
um
if you are that
you know I think I have to fight every
day
like I'm not I'm not a monster
just think I needed help
I think I needed help when I was really
young
and I didn't get it
when I was institutionalized three times
four times
before I was 15.
I was seeing all these therapists
probably wrongly diagnosed you know
it seems like this is a story that
happens with so many people but mine is
just an extreme
you know teenagers all have you know
hormone issues and get a little wild but
do parents you know send their kid off
to one of these residential schools
you know do you look into the
residential school
does it have a
long history of abuse child abuse you
know do they lock kids and
in a cement rooms with nothing
now here's the here's the crazy part
about prison and Provo
prison we had beds
in ourselves when we were in trouble
um even our dry cells
when you know you accuster things they
would put you in a dry cell to force you
to take stuff out of you whatever that
is you know me it would mostly be Motors
because I'm a tattoo artist so
it would put you in a dry cell but you'd
still have a cot and a sink and a toilet
and Provo as as you know a 15 year old
girl which there's lots of girls there
um that you it's you're just on a
nothing you do nothing you're on the
floor in a cement cell in there and
we'll leave you in there for hours
sometimes naked
um
forcing showers on the kids it's
so this institution is doing this thing
when I was a child and in this
institution is a totally different
um monster it's almost like I was
prepped
I was prepped like this this state kind
of prepped me for that and I was just
easy pickings
by the time I was an adult
you know and you're high and you're
getting preyed on by a man that's twice
your age who is a predator
you know because I said the wrong thing
to the cop when I was high I got charged
with first-degree murder
because of that so um I was just easily
preyed on
um I think from Jump Street really
from
birth with CPS doing that strange
adoption over state lines that makes no
sense
um
to Institute child institutions to
prison
kind of set you up it seems like
it seems like everybody's kind of making
money off of
um
trauma
you've been out for how many years now
I've been out for
six years four off of parole
where's your life stand now or do you
have kids I have a child I have one son
you're raising him yes with his father
we live on the lake
um I live I need to kind of be alone
you know
um so I live away from people really
peaceful I don't know if that's maybe
good for everybody but it's really
peaceful and that's all I care about
unlike you know Texas and your life is
better now no drugs no no smoke weed you
know but no no drugs
and looking back at this
crazy past of years looking back at your
past do you
blame your parents do you blame the
environment you're in your DNA what do
you there's a lot of circumstances I
blame oh the nature versus nurture
question
um that's a big one with me because I
wasn't raised with
um you know the the nature
um
I believe that
the circumstances
um you know adopting adopting a kid
isn't what it's cracked up to be I don't
think that's the answer
um people think it is adopting a
potentially damaged psychologically
um or physically
um adopting that's a big
it's a big responsibility I don't think
people really grasp
the the severity of being
you know abandoned as a child
it's a detrimental yeah
seriously
traumatizing you know I think it's kind
of minimized maybe I'm sure you've seen
it a lot doing what you do sure half the
people in your adopted
it is a small percentage though at the
same time
um
so there was that it was a it was a
the racial
I didn't feel a part connected to a
family which I probably needed
desperately being I should not have went
to her
the way I was
well I guess we could route this all to
uh CYFD corruption really that's where
it all started that's where my trauma
started
was
um me coming out of a junkie home abused
and then somehow going across state
lines and getting to a woman who
would she was under the impression that
I was going to that I didn't have any
other family I have a of a brother I
have a whole other family
um that I just disappeared from
uh they had no idea what happened to me
so
how I ended up with a woman who was just
a teacher at Hollywood High
um
we're kind of in the slums really
um
remember sewer everywhere we would step
on plastic Lids Tupperware Lids to walk
across and this was when I was three
four
um she was
basically dying of melanoma cancer as
well
um
how I was how that how I was able to not
saying that she didn't do the best that
she could you see what I mean but how I
was able to
um end up with her
um
it's probably the first start of a
a roller coaster events of
not making much sense you mentioned how
you like to be isolated now as an adult
would what other effects have your
childhood had on you
uh
well yeah I just I like to
coming out here
too super stressful super stressful
there's a lot of people
um
I am just going to say it like this I'm
you know what we actually all I'm not
going to beat myself up over this okay
everybody's got a little bit of monster
in them all right and mine comes out a
little bit quicker
so I decide to
isolate myself not for
um
yes for my sanity but
maybe for somebody else too you know
if I'm out here and let's just say you
know I'm not in the
the right I'm not in the happiest mood
I'm not you know something's not in I'm
pushed the wrong way I I will uh lash
out violently
so
um I don't want to be
I want to be a violent person I'm not in
prison
I don't need to gouge somebody's eyes
out
you know
Samantha what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in all
of this
I really just
don't want to do the same thing
um to my child
um being isolated not having
um
Family Support not having I just want
you got to start with the children
right
that's it really you gotta start with
the children because if you um
the only thing I've learned is yeah
taking care of
you don't want to grow up and be an
ugly person and hurt people that
you know potentially didn't have
didn't deserve it maybe you know nobody
deserves to
to get your
traumatic
[ __ ] off your chest on somebody else
does that make you see what I mean
um
that's the only thing I've learned
to treat our children right
you know listen to them
you know because I was struggling
really really I'm struggling as a child
I'm screaming out lashing out I mean
gosh I was living in a tent and I was so
young dangerous dangerous out here for
you know a little girl in Los Angeles to
live like that I'm surprised I'm alive
um
so
screaming out for help
and uh maybe the drug use
just maybe all of all of this other
self-destructive stuff is uh that people
do
um
and and out you know this is out or two
you know
um it affects every we all affect
everyone
everything I did as a kid everything I
did as an adult
um
at times I feel like I yeah I was forced
to kind of turn into an animal to
um fit into that mold that I was in
um
you don't have you don't have to
I guess you just gotta
know how to control your animal
and if you can't control it then yeah go
live out on the lake where it's really
peaceful and you hear birds outside and
you know
all right Samantha thank you so much for
sharing your story
wish you the best of luck now thanks